once i don't understand repeating the
joke you know
royce i've been watching the show for
about a year now and i am a big fan
i want a motion for this to be the new
day wave anthem
see how not cowboys are all right let's
go back to the cowboys
you're hanging out you're hanging out
with you with your boys having a good
time and women show up and then what do
they do
they ruin everything kill the fun man
we're trying to hang out
no sleeves on play pinball kill jerk
each other off
can i play this really cool music video
that i think you're gonna like have you
heard of the scat bros
are they the the poop themed band
i don't like this guy's old west
gunfighter mustache are you kidding
that's the best mustache
ever i stan hanson in this video what is
this role on math 2 in this video
let's play out the song you donated you
[Music]
might
okay this changes things i'll leave you
with this
i'll leave you with this sorry about our
theme song for day wave
because you hang out with the fellas
here all right i'll put a little music
like this
there's men being men and you could
argue with me if you want but you know
i'm right
all right i'll cleanse the palette i'll
show you guys hang out with the fellas
you know what i'm gonna do we're gonna
hang out with the fellas real quick
let's hang out with the fellas
who's my favorite scat boy uh sporty
scat who's your favorite
there's no need for this there's
absolutely zero need for this
and now and now you guys know
you guys don't even deserve it but i'll
cleanse the palette you don't deserve it
for the scat bros
all [ __ ] day you guys you guys
thought i was [ __ ] around with the
scat bros
but they're musically talented people
and i'm really sick you guys saying
they're not
django unchained what a great cowboy
film right
what an amazing what an amazing cowboy
film
we're playing three amigos
here we go you guys listen i'm turning
you guys around you guys are gonna love
you guys already love the outpost and
you [ __ ] know it
all right let's get the blood pump in
here it's almost no more hours so i need
to try to energize myself let's energize
ourselves guys
let's hang out with the fellas real
quick ladies you can leave for a little
bit go to the kitchen or whatever
really sorry that we haven't done this
that's this is all on me and i apologize
so here you go
[Music]
i didn't know there was another cover of
this
[Music]
at the outpost i like these guys i am
gonna lie to you and i'll leave you with
this
i'll leave you with this i appreciate
all donations i appreciate you guys
being here and i hope all of you have a
fantastic
and wonderful day bye
bye sweating